Congratulations, you've finished lesson three.
In this lesson, you used remotes to push changes up to GitHub and
pulled down changes made by other people.
You also got practice using pull request to collaborate with other people.
This is also the end of the course.
We hope you enjoyed it.
We certainly had fun making it.
What was your favorite part about making the course, Sarah?
>> Oh, I really enjoyed thinking about how all the concepts fit together, so
we could draw the concept map.
What about you?
>> Hm.
It's a tough question.
But I really enjoyed adding color to the Asteroids game.
I was so excited when I got that working.
>> What about you guys?
What did you like about the course?
Or what do you wish that we had done differently?
Go to the forums to tell us what you think.
>> Thanks again for joining us.
And remember to use Git on your next project.